[Musique]
et
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire pour un débat à quatre
enfin comme avant le cobp id met à
distance bien entendu un débat sur la
cancel culture alors la culture de
l'effacement français là quand cette
culture c'est la façon dont les
minorités américaines les afro
américains les isp ai dit que les
asiatiques les homosexuels et trans ou
les femmes réplique tôt fait qu'ils ou
elles ont été longtemps effacé de
l'histoire des états unis
en effaçant à leur tour par exemple en
déboulonnant les statuts nous avons
consacré un débat à ce sujet il y a deux
mois
mais on peut aussi vouloir effacer des
gens bien vivant parce qu'ils sont
accusés sur les réseaux sociaux dans les
médias d'être des violeurs des racistes
des pédocriminels des islamistes des
homophobes ou des transphobes c'est
arrivé à romane polanski à gabriel
matzneff lalique du lol ou à yassine
belattar eux aussi doivent disparaître
comme les statuts de colbert ou du
maréchal bugeaud
alors pour ou contre la cancel culture
pour en débattre nous avons invité
marion messina qui est romancière vous
êtes l'auteur de faux départ au
dilettante vous avez signé la tribune
collective de l'hebdomadaire marianne
contre la cancel culture tout comme
isabelle alonso thomas guénolé jean
michel ribes ou fabrice epelboin
pourquoi l'avez-vous signé en deux mots
je les signe et parce qu'aujourd'hui la
culture de l'effacement c'est une arme
politique
c'est un moyen comme un autre de se
débarrasser de ses adversaires on leur
colle une étiquette sans avoir à prouver
quoi que ce soit pour pouvoir s'en
débarrasser pour pouvoir leur interdire
de se défendre pour que le doute reste
toujours collé sur leur front et pour
qu'ils soient handicapés socialement
avis véritablement avis c'est une arme
politique avant d'être une arme de
défense de qui que ce soit et c'est très
dangereux
fatima benamar vous avez milité à osez
le féminisme au front de gauche à
l'association les effrontés que vous
avez co fondé
on vous a vu manifester par exemple
contre le film j'accuse de roman
polanski et les douze nominations qu'il
avait reçues aux césar n'hésitez pas à
encourager la cancel culture vous
pourquoi
en fait je n'encourage pas vraiment la
cancel culture parce que j'ai
l'impression que c'est un mot qui est
assez mal choisi c'est à dire qu'il ya à
la fois la question de la censure de
contenus qui sont ou bien relève de la
liberté d'opinion ou bien qu'ils
contreviennent à la loi parce que le mot
conseil culture est venu dans dans le
débat par monsieur girard concernant
gabriel matzneff darryl matzneff sera
jugé l'année prochaine sur le fait que
sa littérature était son oeuvre était
une propagande une apologie de la
pédocriminalité et j'ai l'impression
qu'un peu comme après mythe où il y à ce
mot qui a importé pour essayer encore
une fois face à des militants qui essaie
de comprendre les mécanismes qui font
l'impunité en france et qu'ils font
l'euphémisation et la longue
condamnation des violences sexuelles
pour rechercher une forme de statu quo
ils nous disent attention si vous allez
tirer le fil des responsabilités des uns
et des autres et de tout ce qui a fait
le système de leur impunité
ce n'est pas d'ailleurs que christophe
girard en soit c'est c'est tout le
système qui a encouragé qui a protégé
qui a financé monsieur matzneff et qui
lui a donc permis de commettre ses
crimes
du moment qu'on veut interroger ces
mécanismes pour qu'ils ne se
reproduisent pas eh ben on dit qu'on
fait attention il y aurait un danger de
la cancel culture comme il y a trois ans
au moment des mythes où on nous a dit
attention il y aura un danger d'une
france qui advient où il y aura plus de
drague ou un homme ne pourra plus aller
dans un ascenseur ou des carrières
seront détruites et ses hommes je pense
qu'après trois ans on peut se dire que
nous sommes très loin de ses prévisions
la east of girard que vous venez de
citer c'était l'adjoint à la culture de
david algo à paris il a dû démissionner
suite à des manifestations devant
l'hôtel de ville pour une seule raison
parce qu'il avait été cité comme témoin
dans la sphère matzneff pas du tout
parce qu'il était soupçonné quoi que ce
soit il
sauf que depuis lors quelqu'un un garçon
aurait porté plainte contre lui
mais pour l'instant on n'en sait pas
tellement plus dany robert dufour lui et
philosophe universitaire vous êtes
l'auteur de l'art de réduire les têtes
c'était en 2003 votre dernier livre ces
baisses ton prochain c'est un essai sur
le capitalisme paru chez actes sud
vous aussi vous faites partie des
signataires de la tribune collective
contre les camps de cette culture paru
dans marianne vous aussi pourquoi l'avez
vous signez je vais signer parce que je
suis philosophe et donc je pense que
effacé quelqu'un ou effacer des
arguments d'un débat ne permet pas
justement de tenir de débats et là on
est au coeur donc d'une question
philosophique y donc fonctionne depuis
les lumières avec le discours argumenté
la contre argumentation
et donc c'est cela qu'il faut maintenir
et effacer des gens effacé déboulonner
les statues toute une série de pratiques
dont qui ont à voir avec l'effacement
justement ne permettent pas juste de
construire ce qui est indispensable aux
chantiers de toufik et à la démocratie
c'est à dire le débat région cénac
politiste sociologue spécialisé dans les
questions d'égalité de discrimination de
diversité vous avez été membre du haut
conseil à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes vous avez même été présidente
de la commission sur la parité êtes
l'auteur de l'égalité sans condition aux
éditions rue de l'échiquier
alors j'avais envie de vous demander
pourquoi n'avez-vous pas signé la
tribune de marianne mais plus
précisément car rapport entretenez-vous
avec la consult culture
alors ce qui est intéressant tant que
politiste c'est le récit et les
controverses qui sont portées autour de
ce terme qui un terme difficile parce
qu'il est difficilement traduisible à il
il renvoie d'ailleurs à une amérique
diaboliser pour mieux idéaliser la
france et c'est vrai que ce qui est
intéressant
la manière dont vous posiez la question
d'ailleurs été une alternative binaire
entre ceux qui étaient pour et ceux qui
étaient contre
comment pourrait-on être tour à redire
on est dans quelque chose ou de toute
façon ce terme
il est fait pour discréditer une ceux
qui aspirent à lever le voile à moi je
crois que celle inverse de l'effacement
s'est levé le voile sur la complexité de
notre histoire sur la complexité de
rapport à aux responsabilités dans un
pays qui a été construit et cette
tribune est intéressante à analyser a
été construit sur une forme
d'idéalisation de pays des droits de
l'homme le philosophe qui est aussi
virtuellement sur ce plateau et je pense
pas dupe du fait que ces droits de
l'homme n'ont concerné que des frères
qui étaient minoritaires et qui étaient
des hommes blancs
donc pour moi ceux qui sont dans le
récit de l'effacement c'est ce qui porte
encore cette vision complètement
idéalisé d'une france des droits de
l'homme et des droits fondamentaux
quand je dis cela je pense que là où
c'est à un débat piégeux piégeant c'est
que il est toujours sain de rappeler la
nécessité d'être exigeant en particulier
dans les milieux programme si c est donc
en particulier en france 2 de gauche
la nécessité d'être soucieux de
respecter les droits fondamentaux et en
particulier la liberté d'expression et
le respect de la dignité et des
personnes donc là dessus je pense que il
ya une forme de consensus sur ce point
là alors que le fait de brandir la
cancel culture ferait penser qu'il ya
toute une partie progressiste que ce
soit aux états unis ou en france en plus
on fait des amalgames entre les deux qui
serait pour effacer comme ça sans
d'autres raisons que le fait de vouloir
censurer parce que avec une vraiment une
forme d'intégrisme
des personnalités donc moi je trouve que
ce qui est intéressant et je me réjouis
de pouvoir en discuter avec vous c'est
que par exemple christophe girard dans
son communiqué de presse de démission de
l'as de la mairie de paris
il brandit le maccarthysme donc c'est
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que quand
on parle d'un qu'ils y sion on va
stigmatiser l'inquisition ou là où la
censure aux états unis alors qu'on en a
déjà aussi dans notre histoire française
il va brandir sa mais quelque part c'est
pour une manière de ne pas parler de ne
pas discuter de faire écran à sa
responsabilité politique et personnel
donc moi je trouve ça intéressant tu
toujours et on l'avait vu aussi face
amis tout sur la liberté d'importuner
que on va opposer ses droits
fondamentaux que sont la liberté et
l'égalité comme si on avait à choisir
entre l'un et l'autre
or comment est-ce qu'on pourrait être
vraiment libre si on n'est pas égaux
donc moi là dessus je trouve qu'il ya
vraiment deux poids deux mesures sur le
fait qu on dîne ce qu'on ait fait
effacer christophe girard ou gabriel
matzneff alors qu'eux ils ont quand même
été dans l'impunité très longtemps ou
polanski qui est pourtant a été
condamnée est encore libre alors qu'on
va pas parler par exemple ou très peu en
tout cas on n'a pas utilisé ce terme de
cancelles culture pour l'heure rokhaya
diallo avec une affaire très récente
pour alice coffin qui a subi un cyber
harcèlement
donc là dessus moi je ne suis assez gêné
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle de
d'effacement et de cancelles culture
uniquement comme ça on concerne la
remise en code de comportement raciste
sexiste pédophiles et non pas quand ça
touche des personnes qui au contraire
portent ces enjeux qui sont au coeur
normalement de la mise en oeuvre des
fameux droits de l'homme alors
effectivement dans le cas d'élise coffin
d'ailleurs il ya sa photo qui est prévu
on a plein de photos prévu y compris des
gens dont l'effacement entre guillemets
a fait consensus pense à bertrand cantat
par exemple il a été effacé il a eu beau
purger sa peine quand il a voulu
remonter sur scène ou quand un magazine
l'a mis en couverture on a dit ça n'est
pas possible il y avait un large
consensus
pour le dire on pourrait citer
évidemment dieudonné et beaucoup
d'autres il ya eu des tentatives aussi
d'effacement qui n'ont pas forcément
fonctionné on peut passer par ces yann
moix à eric zemmour qui en dépit du fait
qu'il a été condamné que de nombreuses
personnes ont dit qu'ils ne méritaient
plus de travail et il a quand même deux
émissions de télévision
donc on voit bien qu'il ya des
tentatives d'effacement de toutes sortes
ça ne date pas d'hier et j'imagine
mariant messina ça vous choque
à chaque fois où finalement on veut bien
effacer ses propres adversaires mais on
n'a pas envie d'effacer ceux qui
éventuellement pourraient nous être plus
sympathique
réjane je suis désolé je suis très fier
oublié son nom de famille j'adore parler
d'égalité pour que nous puissions être
libre voilà je lui demande de bien vous
de bien m'excuser donc à elle évoqué le
fait que nous puissions être tous égaux
face à la possibilité d'effacement pour
être libre dans ce cas pourquoi y at il
eu toujours effectivement une une
condamnation à deux vitesses pourquoi
condamne sont les propos sexistes d'un
vieux mâles blancs parce que c'est dans
l'air du temps et pourquoi autorise-t-on
absolument les propos sexistes d'un bon
ben adda p ain el sous prétexte que ce
serait pop culture ou parce que ça
appartiendrait à une ère on va dire
culturelle différente de celle des beaux
quartiers
c'est très compliqué en fait de pouvoir
effacer de manière uniforme
j'ai beaucoup de mal à ne pas voir une
revanche politique dans un certain
nombre de cas l'initiateur la tribune
que nous avons signé à marianne elle est
sur l'initiative d'un homme qui
s'appelle thomas guénolé qui a été
évincée de la france est soumise sur
accusations de harcèlement sexuel
on l'a convoqué à la france aso nuisent
1 samedi en lui disant qu'il y avait des
accusations de harcèlement contre lui il
ne sait même pas qui a porté plainte
contre lui il ne sait pas ce qui lui a
été reprochée il a une étiquette et de
harceleur sexuel sur le front ceux qui
connaissent la france insoumise savent
qu'il ya encore en poste aujourd'hui des
gens qui sont vraiment de harceleur
sexuel et contre qui personne ne porte
plainte et je tairai leur nom
mais est il ya vraiment de quoi rester
circonspect devant cette propension à
jeter l'anathème sans droit de défense
parce que les médias généralement ne
vérifie que très peu leurs sources avant
de colporter les propos il ya très peu
l'usagé du conditionnel les procédures d
année est la mise au pilori en fait elle
est éternelle et le danger en fait face
à ça c'est que des gens qui pourrait
revenir sur leurs propos qui pourraient
faire amende honorable et qui pourrait
peut-être passer à autre chose
sont tentés de continuer dans les
extrêmes je pense par exemple que
quelqu'un comme dieudonné en 2003 qui
fait son sketch de mauvais goût sur la
colonisation israël n'est pas antisémite
je pense qu'il est vraiment contre la
colonisation d'israël
quand tout d'un coup il se fait jeter de
partout quand toutes ces connaissances
tous ses anciens associés se met à lui
cracher à la figure
au bout de quelques années on voit que
ça devient un antisémite notoire
si vous écrivez des choses en marchant
sur des oeufs et qu'on voudrait
d'extrémistes la tentation c'est de
vraiment de le devenir est en réalité on
va vers une bipolarisation qu'on
pourrait largement évitées donc je pense
que la culture de l'effacement elle a
aussi cet effet pervers de dire aux
jambes a maintenant qu'on vous a collé
une étiquette il va falloir l'assumer
vivre avec et donc on force des gens à
jouer un personnage ou à adopter une
posture qu'on leur a assigné fatima ben
ammar on a l'impression que d'un côté
certains disent vous avez assisté sur la
notion d' impunité il y aurait des gens
qui auraient des défis sied de
l'impunité s'ils ont bénéficié de
l'impunité c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
plainte un tout simplement en tout cas
en france je pense à roman polanski
il n'y a pas de plainte donc pas de
raison que il ne soit pas dans
l'impunité il était il y avait des
problèmes aux états unis pas en france
où gabriel matzneff évidemment mais ça
on ne va pas faire un débat ni sur lundi
sur l'autre mais vous parler d'impunité
mais visiblement en face aussi on dit il
ya une impunité de là pour ceux qui
accusent au fond qui accuse qui
demandent qu'on les cons l'écho les
fasse disparaître qu'ils perdent leur
travail qu'il n'est plus de prix qu'il
n'est plus de récompenses qui n'est plus
rien mais là aussi une impunité puisque
se basent parfois sur des ouï-dire des
ragots des candiens n'y a pas au fond il
n'y a pas ce qui nous semble toujours le
plus important une vraie preuve déposée
au commissariat
je pense qu'il ya deux choses c'est pas
pour rien qu'on a parlé d' omerta après
8 ou c'est à dire que la faire il ya eu
une éruption de la parole après laffaire
veinstein qui avait sept symptomatique
c'est effectivement personne n'avait
porté plainte et à la fois c'était un
secret de polichinelle c'est à dire que
tout le monde savait et beaucoup de gens
en témoigner a posteriori de la
déchéance on va dire de monsieur
einstein que oui tout le monde savait
qu'il était son comportement et ses îles
sollicitude envers les femmes
c'est à dire qu'il y avait une omerta
halles à la base bien parce que ces
hommes étaient trop puissants pour qu'on
puisse même tenté de porter plainte pour
beaucoup d'autres femmes
si elle parlait elle portait plainte est
le problème qui reconnut je pense
maintenant au plus haut niveau de l'état
c'est les classements sans suite c'est à
dire qu'on est dans un pays où on aime
quand on va porter plainte il ya 10% de
choses que le violeur soit condamné
c'est à dire que moi ce que j'ai fait
les plus dans mon association c'est de
l'accompagnement des victimes dans les
commissariats et les gendarmeries et je
peux vous assurer que la première chose
que je leur dis aux victimes c'est ça va
être classée sans suite il faut voir
comment on va penser l'après et enfin
nitoo a mis une une situation en france
qui a permis que les femmes puissent
parler enfin et c'est ce qui a fait
qu'on a eu l'impression qu'on remonter
loin dans l'histoire pour aller chercher
des dossiers d'une part que ce soit
valence vanessa spring orale adèle
haenel il a fallu qu'elle même
grandissent walesa string aura pourtant
tout était écrit noir sur blanc dans la
littérature de made in f mais il a fallu
qu'elle grandisse qu'elle prenne la
parole qu'elle écrive un livre le
contentement pour qu'on voie ce qui
trouvait les yeux finalement dans sa
situation
adèle haenel il paraît que toutes les
personnes selon les enquêtes de
mediapart était au courant de ce qui se
passait pendant le tournage et ont
témoigné en sa faveur mais il a fallu
que les années passent et qu'elle
grandisse et qu'elle prenne la parole
pour que cette réalité soit reconnue et
puis il ya eu le fait qu'il ya quelques
années c'était un sacerdoce d'en parler
souvenons nous de la faire tristane
banon qui prend la parole sur le viol
dont elle accuse la tentative de viol
dont elle accuse dominique strauss kahn
et qui est jeté en pâture dans le
traitement médiatique et dans l'opinion
aujourd'hui les femmes par là même quand
il ya une énorme inégalités de position
je prends un exemple symptomatique des
masseuses et de patrick bruel il ya une
masseuse qui a levé la voix qui n'a pas
voulu se taire et qui a dit voilà
monsieur patrick bruel m'a demandé de
faire de la falaise perd seulement un
massage mais d'avoir des pratiques
sexuelles avec lui et il m'a mis la
pression pour faire ça et là il ya
plusieurs autres femmes qui commencent à
parler et ne me semble pas que
aujourd'hui la carrière de patrick bruel
soit en quoi que ce soit remis en cause
par rapport à la cancel culture sur la
manière dont elle a été amenée dans le
débat par monsieur girard sait que la
ferme à 19 et tellement symptomatique
que l exiger qu'il ait un débat global
soit posée dans dans la société et les
automatiques à plusieurs égards parce
que elle met tout un système qui a duré
des décennies
face à ce qui n'était même pas un secret
de polichinelle à ce qui était quelque
part dans le débat admis on a revu les
images des missions qui ont été faites
et c'est pas pour rien que le l'article
du new york times parce que c'est nous
est venue des états unis il a fallu
qu'un article des murs new york times
commencent à pointer du doigt les
responsabilités des uns et des autres
qui ont permis à madina de commettre ses
crimes pendant des décennies sans être
inquiété c'est pas pour rien que cette
partie de s'appeler lean it françaises
sur le banc des accusés c'est à dire
qu'on n'a même pas besoin de prouver on
a par exemple la vidéo de monsieur hardy
pas très vieille je vous êtes héros
parce que ils restent plus tellement de
temps il faudrait donner la parole et
puis je voudrais pas qu'on fasse à
débattre sur uniquement sur gabriel
matzneff si on a bien compris votre
poignet ce dernier exemple on a une
vidéo noir sur blanc avec l'audio qui
gâte pas de si longtemps monsieur
arguent ils sont dix à la vidéo
la lame a dit elle ce soir ils rentrent
avec une gamine de 12 ans et demi et moi
avec beigbeder qui a table je dois
rentrer avec une pluie de 60 ans vous
voulez pas qu'on échange et messieurs
attention il est toujours là et monsieur
ardisson il met la vie dure
je ne pense que c'est vraiment un écran
qui en train d'aiguiser complètement au
contraire un système d'impunité qui a
besoin de se maintenir parce que si on
commence à voir comment ce système
d'impunité a été entretenu et toute la
société devra se remettre en cause et
peut-être qu'ils ne sont pas prêts à
faire ça les niais robert dufour qu'est
ce que vous répondez à fatima benomar
bah écoutez moi je crois que le fait de
vouloir des défenses des droits bafoués
une partie de la population que les
femmes se défendre contre donc les
agressions dont elles sont victimes que
des victimes qui ont été esclavage usées
se défendent
tout cela est absolument juste et
légitime la question je le répète
philosophique qui m'importe c'est que
cela ne permet pas de nier la liberté
d'expression d'opinion de débats de
réunion et je pas qu'il faut il faut se
souvenir de ceux de ce principe
fondamental c'est que une cause juste ne
pas être défendue par des moyens un
juste à partir du moment où on efface
une personne on n'est plus du tout dans
l'argumentation qui sert aussi bien à
informer le reste de la population de ce
que cette population ne voyez pas
auparavant
et donc cela vise tout simplement à
discréditer la personne même
sans argumenter sur sur le fond est donc
là il ya toute une pédagogie de
l'argumentation qui s'en va tout
simplement parce que le débat lui-même
part et je crois que ce qui est ce que
je veux dire c'est que les camps de ses
listes à l'aplomb les comme ça ne
débattent pas il excommunie comme dans
la religion et je ne prends pas ce terme
là au hasard
je crois que en effet il ya derrière ce
modèle le modèle du communautarisme
américain du communautarisme identitaire
américain qui n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec le débat à la française encore une
fois il faut défendre les droits bafoués
d'une partie de la population en
instruisant ces câbles en portant
plainte
il y a des lois si des lois ne sont pas
bien cette il faut exiger que d'autres
lois soient mûres fait il y à des
opérations de justice à mener pour que
ceci se passe donc dans l'argumentation
les uns et pas du tout dans la pratique
de l'effacement qui donc annuler annuler
cannes salle c'est quand même
l'effacement et l'annulation alors je
dis ceci brossy parce que j'ai vu cette
culture se répandre dans certains
départements universitaires qui se sont
transformés en enclave très sectaire qui
pratiquait la mise à l'index
d'intellectuels darty d'artistes
d'enseignants tout simplement parce que
ce qu'ils exprimaient n'étaient pas
conformes à leurs dogmes
alors là il ya une façon encore une fois
je crois très américaine de camper sur
la vertu nous sommes vertueux décante se
disent sont vertueux et des autres ne
sont pas graves blessures je vous
interromps dany robert dufour mais on
n'a pas eu besoin d'imiter les
américains on a toujours fait la même
chose
à l'université il n'a jamais été très
bien vu d'être de droite encore moins
d'extrême droite et parfois même d'être
socialiste n'était pas très bien vu
l'université française a toujours en
tout cas pour ce qui est de d'accueillir
des athées rituel a toujours été
sectaire et ça encore une fois ça date
pas d'hier mai 68 avant mai 68 du temps
les communistes étaient plus important
qu'aujourd'hui l'excommunication se
pratiquait déjà ça n'est pas récent je
crois que si il ya des femmes qui sont
des formes récentes avec des
manifestations aux nouvelles qui sont
par exemple l'utilisation de de
l'internet des campagnes de sai vera
harcèlement des campagnes de mails de
masse qui se fonde sur des accusations
complètement infondées que tel ou tel
prof serait donc quelqu'un qui oppriment
les autres qui donc manifeste une espèce
de surpuissance de toute puissance et
qu'il faut le dégommer sens qui lui nier
justement d'argumentation et
d'opposition donc des arguments avec
même une confrontation des points de vue
je dois dire je connais des universités
en france elle a même parisienne où cela
s'est passé qui ont abouti à donc le
fait que les enseignants ont été omis
salekhard simplement pratiquement obligé
d'être de démissionner en portant
justement le la honte sur eux mêmes ce
n'était pas comme ça autrefois on avait
un débat d'idées même si le débat
d'idées était dur là l'opposition
n'était pas entre ceux qui sont vertueux
et ceux qui sont offensants pour pour
les autres je dois dire que ça ne se
passe pas qu'en france par exemple
récemment dans une grande université
étrangère
un de mes livres devait être publié il a
été mise à l'index
il a été ciblé tout simplement parce que
je disais dans ce livre qu'il faut des
il faut distinguer la le le sexe et le
genre
bon on peut changer de genre il ya aucun
problème nous on ne peut pas changer de
sexe parce que dans un cas on est dans
une réalité une réalité biologique et
dans un autre dans un autre cas on est
dans une réalité culturelle
or le comité de lecture a rédigé toute
une série de rapports contre ce livre
parce qu'ils n'étaient que sur la
théorie du genre est donc je suis les
devenu un homophobe et transphobe etc
etc
c'est arrivé a dit carrément et c'est
arrivé a dit mme rowling l'auteure
d'harry potter qui avait dit une chose
sur les transsexuels et qui s'est
retrouvé à son tour la cible de la com
cette culture ont fait une pause on se
retrouve juste après et je donnerai la
parole à are et jade cénac et à marion
messina
[Musique]
oui le 4 août dernier deux explosions
ont dévasté la capitale du liban
beyrouth un coup de grâce pour le pays
déjà bien abîmée par une crise
économique sans précédent du conte sur
la grèce cents par rapport à la grèce il
ya ici une différence c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de risque systémique pour personne
en fait type est synonyme entre ses
foudres
c'est pas comme la grèce ou des les
bailleurs de fonds vole à son secours
aps le risque aujourd'hui c'est la
disparition du liban a déclaré jean yves
le drian sur rtl le 27 août dernier on
injecte des liquidités on injecte de
liquidités en se disant finalement ça
n'aura aucune conséquence voici ça en a
je pense qu'aujourd'hui les libanais en
une opportunité en or pour changer
changer ce statut quo et on espère qu'on
pourra transformer cette terrible crise
qui sera forcément douloureuse en une
opportunité pour que d'ici cinq ou dix
ans on aurait là bien meilleure à nos
enfants
c'est indéniable qu'il ya eu nombre de
satellites qui augmente de façon
incroyable depuis deux trois ans avec
l'arrivée des méga constellation à ces
constellations internet voulait on parle
de les 2000 ou pouvoir
dix mille satellite donc en trois quatre
ans on voyait plus de cette élite que
tout ce qu'on a envoyés en 60 ans donc
finalement le débris spatiaux ont
commencé le jour où on a envoyé l'un des
véhicules dans l'espace est ce que les
états aujourd'hui sont plus responsable
et prenne en compte cette question des
débris des états se doivent de faire
attention à ce que ces compagnies la
respecte bien l'espace pour que les
futures générations puissent continuer
aussi à l'utiliser
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur la corde fait
culture la culture de l'effacement avec
marion messina qui est romancière avec
fatima benamar du collectif non les
effrontés qui dépanne collectif mais une
association elle en est l'une des
cofondatrices avec dany robert dufour
qui est philosophe et avec réjane cénac
qui et politistes et pas sociologue
comme je l'aï dit à tort tout à l'heure
on repense débat et peut-être avec vous
réjane cénac et une nouvelle question
c'est quoi le but dans ces cas là je
voudrais pas encore une fois qu'on
s'arrête à des cas précis comme celui de
gabriel matzneff aude romane polanski
élargissons puisqu'il ya pas que qui
sont qui sont dans le collimateur c'est
quoi le but c on a bien compris il ya
vous luttez contre la contre culture
lutte contre une forme d'impunité
mais comment c'est quoi le but de faire
disparaître de que la personne perdre
son travail que qu'elle perde sa
réputation qu'elle perde son statut
qu'elle perde sa liberté
c'est quoi le but alors déjà moi je suis
embêté par la question parce qu'elle est
complètement biaisé moi je comme je
l'expliquais à lors de ma première
intervention
moi je crois qu'on est politique
complètement ce qui est en train de se
passer en discréditant donc la la la la
remise en cause plus d'un système que
deux paires salins et comme le disait
fait il m'a benomar d'un système qui
avant tout une un système d'impunité en
disant que le but c'est d'effacer des
personnes non le but c'est de mettre en
évidence la nécessité que des individus
mais avant tout un système prenne ses
responsabilités pour justement être
conforme aux droits fondamentaux de
respect des personnes et des respect des
principes d'égalité et de liberté
et là je trouve quand on attrape
vraiment par le petit bout de la
lorgnette et on évite de parler du fond
alors juste par rapport à ce qui a été
dit sur le fait qu'on s'attache plus aux
graves avec moi aura par exemple le code
d'autres chansons moi j'invite donc
manon messina remariant messina
je voulais l'appeler aussi par semblant
puisque gauthier quand on nous appelait
par nos prénoms alors qu'à le philosophe
cpie genre les filles qui se prennent le
bec entre al devient un peu caricatural
là dessus très clairement si vous
regardez le site de madame rapeau si
vous lisez le sociologue karim amour on
voit bien qu'au contraire il y a une
forme d'impunité des chansons qu'on
appelle de la culture populaire
française du brassens du michel sardou
ou plein d'autres du jus l'inter qui
font des appels au viol qui parlent de
violence envers les femmes et qu'on
n'entend même pas alors on l'entend même
pack ans en france et encore moins quand
sont en anglais donc au contraire il ya
une forme de stigmatisation d'une
population
moi je pense qu'il est quand même assez
d inconvenant quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé avec mme aida les petits scène qui
a été elle vraiment effacer et qu'on en
a qui on a demandé de sortir du jeu
parce que la fashion sphère a mis en
évidence des paroles ou des prises de
positions complotistes qui était dans le
passé et sur lesquelles elle est revenue
d'ailleurs alors que marion cotillard
qui avait eu des propos assez similaire
ou mathieu kassovitz eux ils n'ont pas
du tout été effacés si on parle de
michel houellebecq donc on voulait bien
que michel houellebecq
il n'a pas été condamné ni pour ses
propos personnels dans la revue lire où
il dit que la religion musulmane est la
religion la plus con du monde ni pour
son roman soumission et comme le dit
l'historien shlomo sand
si ça avait été une dystopie avec le
fait que c'était la religion juive et
non pas musulmane qui aurait qui aurait
pris le pouvoir
selon lui et je partage son point de vue
ce livre aurait été mis un best-seller
et aurait d'ailleurs été sans doute pour
cela pour antisémitisme
donc moi je pense au contraire que là on
a vraiment risme qui en prisme
complètement faussé et je trouve ça
vraiment dommage parce que ça empêche de
voir où est le problème
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui ceux et
celles qui sont effacées c'est ce qui
marche et on voit par exemple qu'une
femme meurt encore sous le coup de son
conjoint
tous les deux jours et demi pour des
caisses pour donc des arrestations
raciste ou des actes racistes des
personnes subissent des violences sont
effacées physiquement ou moralement pour
des raisons de l'homophobie aussi donc
moi je pense que de ça de focaliser sur
quelques petits stars qui sont remis en
cause pour des positions qu'ils ont pris
ou des comportements qu'ils ont vu on
fait écran à une discussion réelle sur
qu'est ce qu'on vient ont encore
aujourd'hui en france dans cette société
en termes de conséquences du racisme du
sexisme de l'hétéronormativité comme
système et pas seulement parce que le
nab et je vous remets pas en cause le
fait qu'il faut avoir une vigilance en
termes de respect de la liberté
d'expression mais la liberté
d'expression et aussi à équilibrer en
particulier avec la lutte contre
l'incitation à la haine et à la violence
la liberté d'expression n'a jamais été
juridiquement sans limites ni en france
ni aux états unis et là-dessus
d'ailleurs juste je finis là dessus pour
qu'on laisse la place aux débats sur
mitu on a souvent critiqué me tout en
disant c'est remisant la remise en cause
de la justice de la présomption
d'innocence
comme le disait fatima benomar le
problème c'est qu cible femmes ont eu
besoin de ce mouvement pour passer du
jeu subit ou nous solidaires pour
remettre en cause un système qui est
porté par des individus mais qui dit un
système de violence ce site transversale
très concrètement ça a permis de libérer
la parole et ça augmente et les recours
juridiques
donc ça c'est même très intéressant
qu'ensuite ça apporter une ouverture qui
a été porté par le droit et là dessus
aussi soyons humble quand même sur le
pouvoir du droit et moi je crois dans le
droit comme arme apporter l'égalité mais
il faut en donner leur donner les moyens
hélas pour l'instant on en est loin en
ce qui concerne en particulier les viols
il n'a que 10 % de viol qui font l'objet
de recours
donc il ya vraiment une mise sous le
boisseau des viols et danser 10% là pour
cent qui vont faire l'objet de
condamnations donc moi parlons de very
de 2,2 voilà de ce que vivent aussi
la populace que vit la population
française et pas seulement quelques
petits stars qui sont écorchés mais qui
pour la plupart quand ils font partie de
la population dominante continue à être
beaucoup plus visible que clay par
exemple mais la ligue 600 il a dû partir
très vite beaucoup plus vite que
d'autres acteurs et actrices à lyon mais
fina oui j'ai l'impression d'être un
élève de ce2 qui s'est fait taper sur
les doigts c'est formidable je vous
écouterai eric non non vous aviez sans
doute une réaction puisque encore une
fois chacun reproche à l'autre
au fond une forme d'impunité
mais comme vient de le dire régine sénat
qu il ya des gens qui sont effacées
physiquement et c'est quand même plus
grave que ce qu'on efface est encore là
dit qu'on ne passe pas vraiment et c'est
pas toujours facile de les effacer au
fort vous seriez on efface est
véritablement mais la question de
l'impunité est réelle la question des
viols qui ne débouchent sur aucun procès
c'est un vrai problème
je ne pense pas qu'ils effacent et un
témoin dans une affaire de viol vieille
de quarante ans va résoudre le problème
en fait je pense que nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur l'impact dans la sphère
concrètes et dans la sphère juridique
que peut avoir la pratique de
l'effacement que nous voulons condamner
les violeurs il me semble que c'est une
évidence et que nous sommes tous
d'accord avec ça ensuite elles seront
racontées les bons points du côté de
michel sardou ou de pnl bon on va
peut-être passer un peu à autre chose
je suis assez perplexe par rapport à la
tournure de ce débat pour reprendre le
cas de thomas guénolé qui a initié la
tribune que nous avons signés dans
marianne l'accusation de viol ne repose
sur rien donc que fait-on par rapport à
ça et puis ensuite voilà on parle d'une
population dominante qui resterait
constamment dans l'impunité
qu'est ce qu'on appelle population
dominante ni patrick bruel michel sardou
dit gabriel matzneff ne font partie de
la population dominante
tout à l'heure vous avez évoqué joanne
rowling
on a un moment donné eu sur internet une
pétition pour qu'elle ne soit plus
l'auteur de sa propre oeuvre romanesque
on en est quand même là parce que elle a
osé dire
elle a osé faire une blague sur les
règles des femmes et donc des femmes
trans donc qui ont été des hommes
abandonnés l'on prie très mal et on a
attaqué joanne rowling de transphobie
fin
nous sommes en france aujourd'hui fin
juin 1789 et nos salles à versailles
nous discutons du sexe des anges
si j'essayais d'expliquer certains
débats qui valent 1 et façon aujourd'hui
à ma mère je pense que ses yeux
tomberait de ses orbites
nous en sommes à un point où je
considère tout à fait que effacé plus ou
moins matinale soit légitime parce qu'il
a effectivement abusé de gamine par
contre est-ce qu'on va abuser des gens
qui font des blagues douteuses sur une
infime minorité sexuelle de la
population en fait où s'arrête le sens
où s'arrête le prob où s'arrête le droit
de clouer autrui au pilori et on revient
à ce qu'a dit dany robert dufour tout à
l'heure on est en réalité dans un débat
religieux avec des gens qui sont les
tenants de la morale qui excommunie qui
jette l'opprobe et des gens face qui ne
peuvent pas se défendre
voilà donc je suis vraiment perplexe
face à ça le jour où les gilet jaune
vont re débarqué on sera complètement
déboussolé pour les comprendre si c'est
ça le débat en france aujourd'hui
si on est un
un odieux partisans de l'extrême droite
parce qu'on se permet une blague sur des
hommes dans des ateliers en non mixité
qui veulent débarqué en talons parce
qu'il sent enfin enfin on est vraiment
en train de discuter de choses qui ne
concernent pas 99,99 pour cent de la
population
et pourtant les tenants et aboutissants
de ça c'est quand même la censure ceux
de simples présomptions
tout à l'heure vous avez demandé si les
guerres de chapelles n'ont pas toujours
existé où elles ont toujours existé en
revanche les effets de meute sur les
effets sur les réseaux sociaux les
délation anonyme parce que intel qui est
accusé par un groupuscule de transphobes
ne peut pas donner une conférence dans
une librairie enfin on arrive à des
situations pour moi qui sont beaucoup
plus dangereuse qu est ce qu est ce qu
on fait un pari toi est-ce qu'on va
remettre en cause la population
dominante et qu'est ce qu'on appelle de
la population dominante en effaçant des
gens sur des présomptions de culpabilité
le vrai départ en fait je dois vraiment
on est dans les rationalités religieuses
on est dans l'ex communication totale en
fait il m'a benamar mais d'abord il faut
bien noter qu' il ya eu des
excommunications dans tous les sens
qu'on soit bien d'accord
il y en a qui aboutissent et d'autres
qui n'aboutissent pas il suffit pas
d'excommunier et même des très nombreux
à vouloir excommunié pour que la
personne en question soit effectivement
excommunié ce qui a marché avec
effectivement la jeune fille de kaisy
allusion dans un jeu
à la télé n'a pas marché avec yann moix
par exemple eux il y a ce qui a marché
avec matzneff ou avec l'adjoint à la
culture de deux d'anne hidalgo n'a pas
forcément marcher avec d'autres
maintenant fatima bennama la parole est
à vous oui injuste par rapport à ce que
vous disiez sur la question trans
justement c'est assez révélateur ce que
vous dites c'est que vous dites oui on
fait des débats sur l'effacement de
personnes parce qu'elles auraient paquin
et les trans etc
vous dites ça au moment où en france
vient de passer une loi qui permet aux
personnes qui peuvent tomber enceinte
d'accéder à la procréation médicalement
assistée et sans même l'argumenter le
gouvernement a dit les femmes trans les
zones france on va pas les laisser
accéder à la pma donc les hommes trans
sont des personnes qui sont nés avec des
organes féminins qui peuvent tomber
enceinte et qui peuvent accoucher et on
a effacé leur cas on a dit non écoutez
on n'est pas prêt on va dire que les
femmes non six comme vous et moi peuvent
tomber enceinte
voilà on va leur ouvrir la pma et les
autres pour aucune raison biologique
puisqu'elles ont ils ont un utérus etc
on va pas leur ouvrir son droit donc oui
il ya des mobilisations de personnes
qu'ils sont effacées sans aucune justice
ni et respect pour leur égalité quand
vous dites que ma 19 ne faisait pas
partie de la société dominante
sinon il a une position très
particulière il a eu tenir par le fait
d'avoir été bordé c'est à dire qu'il ya
eu tout un système de solidarité
financière morale de gentillesse de du
fait que le l'adjoint au maire le aux
frais de la mairie l'honorer l'invité à
venir aux frais de la mairie manger qui
a eu des cérémonie des récompenses c'est
ce cortège de responsabilité qui lui a
donné cette position pour faciliter
honorable qui ne faisait a priori mais
rien de mal et ceci n'est évidemment pas
anodin qu'il avait dédié un livre la
prunelle de mes yeux un livre qui était
dédiée à la question de vanessa spring
aura sait comment il arrivait par des
led de la mairie et cetera à pouvoir
coucher avec elle dans des hôtels etc et
le livre est dédié à agir a requis les
excuses en disant mais je leur ai que
partiellement lui or tout est dans la
quatrième de couverture la quatrième de
couverture sais je suis un homme de
cinquante et quelques ma copine à 14 ans
et nous devons suivre voilà grâce à
l'aide de certaines personnes donc
l'idée n'est pas d'aller chercher noise
particulièrement à monsieur girard c'est
de comprendre ce système qui a permis
l'impunité la dernière chose puisque on
parlait dé la question des noms de rues
de la décolonisation de l'espace public
des statuts et c'est justement on a
empêché ce débat populaire avoir lieu
l'espace public c'est un espace
politique par excellence est ce qu'on y
met ce qu'on nous ni au nord ou pas est
une question éminemment politique et le
débat alors qu'il a eu lieu dans
d'autres villes n'a même pas pu avoir
lieu en france où on a mis ça de côté et
on s'est même pas posé la question
pourquoi des nombreux et cetera mettez à
l'honneur des esclavagistes des
massacreurs des idéologues raciste et on
met de côté du coup on fait penser que
ce sont des choses qui se sont passées à
nice dans l'histoire passée syfy j'ai
alors que dans l'histoire passée de
manière contemporaine à l'esclavagé à la
colonisation
il ya des personnes qui se sont élevées
il ya gallieni faidherbe bugeaud qui
participait qu'il est théorisé
absolument la supériorité d'une race sur
l'autre et sert à égaliser michel paul
vigné d'octon qui en droit a tellement
peu d'honneur que de mémoire
ils se sont rebellés contre ça et encore
une fois on dit que lacan cette culture
veut effacer des débats ou des parties
de l'histoire au contraire ce que l'on
nous voulons c'est compléter l'histoire
et c'est mettre en lumière moi j'habite
dans le 11e arrondissement pas loin de
l'avenue faidherbe jamais su ce que
c'était qui c'était et pourtant son nom
était
donc le fait de l'honorer des les
montrer dans des positions honorifique
n'enseigne rien de l'histoire aux gens
alors ceux qui accusent les personnes
qui veulent remettre en cause et qui met
en débat le fait qu'on honore ces
personnes pour le coup franc sorte que
des personnes comme moi mon mépris qu il
était le roi pour en finir avec le débat
au southern iliad et puis si problèmes
de transmission fait il a b d'un bar
vous dit comment ça a pu les clift etc
il se trouve qu'en france au contraire
de ce que la plupart des gens croient il
n'y a pas de minorités et de majorité
sexuelle
voilà donc c'est ce qu'on découvrira
probablement quand on aura mis devant un
tribunal
il n'y a pas de lois qui interdisent la
une jeune fille de 14 ans ou à un
couteau un homme de 50 ans de coucher
qu'une jeune fille de 14 ans ça n'est
pas comme si cette paix arrêtons avec le
arrêtons avec gabriel matzneff il n'est
pas là dany robert dufour vous à peut
entendre
écoutez moi je crains que si ce type de
culture ce généraliste à cannes cette
culture se généralise avec donc des gens
qui des groupes des communautés qui
campent sur leurs vertus et qui donc
veulent faire reconnaître leurs vertus
et stigmatise donc que les autres nous
allons aboutir à une sorte de
ghettoïsation de la cité avec des
groupes opposés qui campe donc sur leurs
vertus supposées avec donc toute cette
dimension religieuse d'excommunication
de mise à l'index et qui ne rêveront
plus que d'annuler les autres là je
crois que véritablement au plan
politique sa prose à un sérieux problème
parce qu'on sort alors une dimension
républicaine qui a été bon je suis
absolument d'accord pour dire que la
promesse républicaines de liberté
d'égalité de fraternité n'a pas été
accompli est encore loin d'être
accomplie pour toute la population
mais cela ne justifie pas du tout le
fait de rentrer
c'est ce républicanisme américain qui
n'est pas du tout un universalisme qui
ont contraire une pluralité une
pluralité de points de vue la pluralité
des points de vue par un communautarisme
américain qui campe donc sur des
morceaux d dimension identitaire avec
donc ces différents groupes qui ne rêve
plus dans cette cité ghettoïser que
d'amener les autres là on a une
véritable de questions politiques qui se
pose derrière tous ces débats est bon
c'est ça moi qui bombent m'intéresse
beaucoup
ce n'est pas simplement donc de prendre
toute une série d'exemples comme ça
c'est je crois qu'il ya véritablement
une réflexion à avoir sur la forme qui
est la forme républicaine ou la forme
communautariste dans laquelle on peut
vivre
alors si la promesse républicaine est
loin d'être accomplie il faut la pousser
il faut qu'elle aille beaucoup plus loin
il faut pouvoir faire inscrire dans la
loi ce que la loi n'inscrivaient pas il
faut effectivement révélé des situations
qui ont été masqués qui ont étaient
voilées pendant longtemps des situations
d'oppression mais c'est à l'intérieur
même du droit et de la loi républicaine
qu'il faut pousser c'est pas du tout
justement dans la construction de
groupes ghettoïser qui s'en prennent les
uns aux autres et qu'ils veulent une
rêve plus que ça me salue ddd inde et
les uns les autres pour terminer ce que
je veux dire quand je réfléchisse un peu
des bas donc il m'est revenu un petit
livre du philosophe donc que
schopenhauer qui exporte dans un petit
livre très intelligent qui s'appelle
l'art d'avoir toujours raison
une trentaine de stratagèmes et il place
en dernier ce qu'il appelle l'ultime
stratagème c'est à dire le dernier
recours
je vous cite juste une ligne si on perd
s'aperçoit que l'adversaire on ne peut
pas gagner contre lui il faut alors
tenir des propos désobligeants blessant
grossier c'est un remplacement des
facultés de l'esprit par celle du corps
ou de l'animalité
je crois que le risque qui a derrière
tout ça c'est de substituer le rapport
de forces au rapport de sens et en tant
que philosophe moi je tiens absolument à
part 2
sans ce qui n'est pas compatible avec la
culture de l'effacement des jeunes cénac
alors là dessus on est d'accord moi je
crois que l'enjeu il est vraiment
d'avoir une controverse qui n'ait pas
peur d'eux d'avoir un rapport à la
république qui soit un rapport critique
et dans cette lutte là pour moi je
parlerais pas d'effacement je parlerai
est d'ailleurs donc l'interlocuteur
précédent bien le dire de mise en
visibilité de toutes les contradictions
les apories au sein de l'énonciation du
commun etienne balibar par le bien de sa
en particulier comment le l'institution
et de l'universel dans l'énonciation du
comment qui est aussi celle de la du
fait d'ériger des frontières entre
particuliers est d'être dans des
logiques d'exclusion de certains de
certaine singularité est au coeur de
notre universalisme
donc moi je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est
en train à travers ces débats qui sont
assez a dit qu'une des choses si on en
reste sur la cruciale culture ou en bas
se battre sur des enjeux de noms de
personnes
je trouve ça fort dommage et je trouve
d'ailleurs que le recours à la fois la
morale et à la religion montre bien que
le discrédit et le renvoie à la vertu il
est plutôt du côté de ceux qui
condamnent la console culture comme un
récit où ça serait vraiment des censeurs
qui porterait la cancel culture je vois
que ça fait rien c'est une bonne chose
donc voilà il ya vraiment un problème
je trouve un renversement de
responsabilité qui est assez
déconcertant moi j'espère qu'on va un
peu monter le débat un qu'on va arrêter
de parler droits de l'homme comme si
c'était quelque chose déterré dont
pourrait être fier alors qu' on ne sait
très bien qu'il a fallu attendre le
xxème siècle pour les femmes il droits
de vote
on est que la france était un pays
d'empiré colonial et qu'on attend encore
aujourd'hui les traces et les effets
retour donc je crois que il faut voir la
réalité en face et la réalité elle est
pas binaire elle est complexe mais elle
n'a pas elle n'est pas aussi dans une
grande france qui devrait conserver ce
système
vu comme quelque chose de complètement
rigide et moi je trouve tout à fait
intéressant des lectures beaucoup plus
complexe qui montrent que l'histoire est
faite aussi de remise en cause justement
de ce qu'on a érigé comme statut et
qu'on a à a travaillé sur nos racines
sur notre notre art aussi qui
symbolisent les récits thion qui ont
gagné ou des petits concurrents
donc voila moi je trouve que c'était
intéressant d'exposer notre nos
conceptions mais sur la culture de
l'effacement moi je
je trouve que c'est quand même une
grille de lecture tout à fait partielles
est ce que vous diriez que la cancel
cultures associées appliquée en
particulier avec le cyber harcèlement de
militantes féministes de militants
antiracistes
alice coffin qui a dû quand même qui a
dû être protégé physiquement suite à la
sphère de christophe girard
on voit avec rokhaya diallo on peut
citer énormément d'autres actrices et
acteurs qui remettre en cause ces
inégalités dont l'universalisme a été
aussi le terreau un universalisme qui
n'était pas à l'universalisme du commun
donc moi je ne pense pas qu'il y a
opposé une idéalisation du
républicanisme ou le fait qu'on va
tomber dans un communautarisme
ghettoïser avec des censeurs qui serait
du maccarthysme et on serait tout des
espèces de puritaine religieuse voilà je
pense qu'on a on doit être un poète les
envers les autres et porter quelque
chose qui est plus complexe plus
exigeants on a un vrai que défi un défi
intellectuel mais avant tout un défi
politique un défi social à arriver à
porter une égalité qui soit réellement
une égalité pour toutes et pour tous et
aussi une liberté pour toutes et pour
tous dans le respect des droits
fondamentaux et le dessus je crois qu'on
se retrouve mais avec une lecture qui ne
soit pas le symétrique je sois pas de
leur mission pardon j'ai eu un problème
d'oreillettes
il reste une minute trente
je suis ravi de voir que finalement nous
sommes tous d'accord nous voulons à
desbin
voulons discuter je crois que la
question n'est pas de savoir qui est le
détenteur de la vertu ou qui est la
grenouille de bénitier de l'autre je
pense que la vraie question c'est à
partir de quand des bâtons et à partir
de quand remettons un système donc à
partir de quand considère-t-on que
l'offensé sérieuse peut-on amalgame est
quelqu'un qui se sent offensé avec une
blague une chronique un dessin peut-on
comparer ça à une insulte personnelle
peut-on comparer ça à
des évolutions dans les débats
groupusculaire qui font qu'on se sent
aujourd'hui offensé de choses qui
semblent presque relevé des débats sur
le sexe des anges
moi je pense dernièrement un député qui
a complètement disparu de la circulation
parce qu'il a retweeté un dessin
d'égalité réconciliation
donc est ce que on va atteindre un point
où retweeter quelqu'un ou donner raison
à quelqu'un c'est être assimilé à la
personne en question est donc jusqu'où
va-t-on aller
en fait c'est la question qui
m'intéresse où allons nous poser les
limites
où allons nous commencer à débattre de
ce qui offense an ou deux ce qui doit
appartenir au domaine de l'humour
va-t-on renoncer à l'humour va-t-on
renoncer au débat
et puis en fait je crois que nous sommes
en réalité dans des dents des vraies
guerres intestines
si j'ai bien compris valeurs actuelles a
écrit quelque chose sur rokhaya diallo
mais très franchement je ne sais pas sur
quoi j'avais la chance d'être en
province ou encore pas si longtemps
donc en réalité je m'intéresse ni à
rokhaya diallo ni à valeurs actuelles
quand j'ai eu le vercors sous les yeux
mais sachez qu'aujourd'hui la ligue de
défense
la ligue de défense africaine un
groupuscule de ce genre a débarqué dans
les locaux de valeurs actuelles pour
essayer de casser des gueules donc en
réalité nous sommes déjà dans des
guerres intestines et maintenant il
importe de savoir jusqu'où cela va
impacter la société civile et puis
encore jusqu'où le droit va-t-il évoluer
pour tout ce à quoi je n'ai pas entendu
par dante et la femme cette émission
mais effectivement fatima ben ammar a
raison c c'est la députée au bono qui a
été qui a été
mise en cause en retard en tout cas
décidé dans valeurs actuelles et qui a
valu l'anecdote que vous racontez je
vous remercie tous les quatre d'avoir à
ce débat et
et il est probablement pas fini merci de
nous avoir suivis et rendez vos
prochains numéros on est très en retard
[Musique]